hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll 21
who is listening to this in the future
100 years from now who knows I don't
know a thousand years from now how long
are people gonna be listening to the
mindscape podcast no one could tell but
this is being recorded in the midst of
what is still kind of a quarantine for
the kovat 19 pandemic chasing around the
world in some places in the world things
are looking up a little bit not
everywhere where I am in Southern
California not really looking up right
now but what I want to talk about today
is actually not viruses or pandemics but
the metaphor I just sneaked in to that
little intro there I was talking about
things looking up turns out that if you
think about it we use these visual
metaphors all the time for things that
have nothing to do with actual vision
when I say that things are looking up in
certain parts of the world I don't mean
that the people there are looking into
the sky or at their ceilings or anything
like that but vision is something that
gives us such clear and distinct
information about the world around us
that we tend to privilege it over the
other senses so today's guest and Sophie
Barbic is against that she thinks that
we are privileged envision too much in
fact she is a philosopher who has
decided to specialize in the sense of
smell and therefore almost inevitably
her first book which is just about to
come out in which I can highly recommend
to you is called a smell Asif II but
it's not just about you know we should
think in this in that way about what we
smell it's about the fact that by
thinking of other senses other than
vision we get a new window onto how the
brain works how consciousness works how
we perceive the world and think about it
and I really admire what Ann has done
because not only is she a philosopher
who was blazing new ground in this way
of thinking about the world but along
the way to learning how to do this she
of course had to learn some neuroscience
she hung out with neuroscientists and at
some point someone said like look you're
doing and thinking so much about
neuroscience why don't you just start
your own lab which she has done she is
now a working neuroscientist as well as
a philosopher taking data you know
buying the lab equipment that whole bit
that's the kind of interdisciplinary
move that I really
admire and that's the kind of people I
like to have here on the mindscape
podcast and I think that you'll really
enjoy the conversation not only will you
learn some new things about how smell
works and what it means but it does help
to you know remind you of some of the
assumptions that are just there in the
background when we think about how the
brain works and how we think about the
world let me just very briefly mention
you know for those of you who don't ever
drop by we do have a website for the
podcast preposterous universe comm slash
podcast where not only can you get show
notes for the episodes and links so for
example you get a link to aunt Sophie's
new book but also there are full
transcripts for every episode which are
paid for by income from the patreon that
we also have and you can find the
patreon also on the website so don't
just listen to the podcasts if you have
the chance check out the website there's
a bounty of information there look at it
smell it whatever it is you want to do
so with that let's go
[Music]
and Sophie bar which welcome to the
mindscape podcast well thank you for
having me
so you're making a claim in your new
book and in your work more broadly for
the importance of smell both
scientifically and philosophically so I
mean let me start off just by letting
you give the sales pitch for spell you
you make the case that we sort of tend
to privilege vision and sight when we
talk about how our minds comprehend the
world and you think that we should be
paying more attention to smell indeed I
do so most of our understanding of mind
and brain is based on the visual system
and for two reasons one reason is that
well we see things it's immediate to our
consciousness so if we talk about
objects of perception for sexual objects
these kind of things we think of visual
things but you can't really apply the
same notion so easily to smell so if you
think of something well what's the
boundary of a smell well what's the it
is the discreteness of a smell and even
if we think of something like
orientation it kind of doesn't make no
sense to say well there's an orientation
of a smell and also the way we talk
about mental stuff it's always about
pictures it's always about images of
thought images these kind of things and
I thought well hang on a second do these
ideas also apply to smell and it seemed
to be first of all that this was a very
neglected area for a long long time and
then furthermore that actually we have
to rethink these central concepts and
perhaps that tells us not only about
other senses but also some new things
about vision okay yeah and so maybe we
can compare it to vision a little bit I
guess that the the typical person would
think of vision first as the thing that
gives us the most accurate picture of
the world in fact just using the word
pictures sort of prejudicial there is it
is your claim that you get an equally or
more accurate view of the world through
smell or just it's a different view and
one that it should be given equal
prominence it's a very good question
because I have a little bit of an
unorthodox view I think that the nose is
actually harder to fool then
I think it's much more accurate actually
it's very easy to fool your visual
system through illusions so this is
people who work on the visual system
know that actually we just thinks
smelling is not so objective or not so
real or gives us no sufficiently
material or substantial account of the
world because it seems so subjective we
all smell things differently not just
you and I would smell this the same
owner potentially as different kind of
qualities but even you yourself the same
smell varies over time whether you smell
it now or later etc and this actually is
a good point about smell because it is
not there to have just a stability of
always the same quality for the same
stimulus but always in relation to your
own physiology and to the environment so
it's an incredibly accurate measure of
context and it often is harder to fool
then visual illusions a visual illusion
where actually you can quite often fool
the retina by by having two images that
are different but that elicits the same
kind of mental image yeah I mean we
think that one reason why there are
visual illusions is because our brain
does a lot of processing on what we see
right it's it's not this very simple
picture that we're just video cameras
recording reality but we get some visual
stimulus and then we put it together in
some complicated way and what you're
saying is that it in I think what you
saying let me let me paraphrase
sometimes we can trick the brain by
using its favorite ways of putting
things together from the visual input
but it's harder to trick it from its
olfactory input absolutely and what is
kind of cool to know is that in the 19th
century one of my favorite historical
scientists Hammond for Helmholtz he
actually made that claim already he said
well actually a lot of visual images
have the same pattern on the retina in
the brain and so we have to for instance
therefore we have to move to figure out
the differences between images and with
smell for instance it's actually much
harder to fool because not only are you
in direct contact with the chemicals but
also um the context is part of the
reason why you smell a certain thing as
a certain thing right and
I can see why the science of how this
works the science of how you go from the
sensory input
to the reconstruction of reality in your
brain is fascinating but you at least
started life as a philosopher I mean you
seem to be a rare person who is becoming
more of a scientist over time and less
of a philosopher but I mean maybe not
less of a philosopher but at least more
fraction of your time is spent literally
in a lab but so what is the particularly
philosophical impact of this is this
really changing how we perceive reality
or something like that
oh absolutely actually so one of the
things that I always found fascinating
is how we how can we actually think of
objectivity of reality if we all
perceive it in a different way and this
is often a cause for relativism that
well we all have different perspectives
and we can't have an objective truth or
ground truth and I thought hang on a
second maybe maybe the question is ill
phrase maybe they're the questions miss
frames and smell was a beautiful sense
to think about that because it has been
neglected for the whole time it's kind
of a Cinderella of the senses so to
speak it's always been like philosophers
had just bad things to say about it well
it's it has nothing to do with publisher
and it's like this subjective sense it's
a brutish sensation it's unimportant my
favorite quote actually is by Immanuel
Kant who said well you know it's the
most dispensable and ungrateful sense
and it doesn't you know it doesn't it
doesn't give you much pleasure because
there are many more stinky things than
good ones and I thought hang on a second
a wide scant the current authority on
pleasure I mean this is a business
figure I possibly was the least funniest
person on earth smart yeah but not
really funny in that sense yeah and this
kind of prompted me all these kind of
negative images about smell is it's just
something neglectful so like why hang on
a second is that really true and then to
a look at smell a lot of philosophical
questions opened up when it comes to how
many senses are there even just how many
senses of smell are there and actually
there are two and my favorite example of
why smell is really interesting also
from a philosophical perspective is when
you would ask people how many sense of
smell do you have
they would look at you as if you're a
little bit crazy so well one of course
you've got you know one noose and you
smell smells so like with a question of
thought but actually it's two so
everything you call taste when you when
you taste something you know strawberry
or mint or vanilla etc there is actually
smell well we kind of knew that because
if you if you have a cold you can't
smell it's like you can't smell and you
can't taste a thing so this is even
human oh it can't must have had coals
and you still didn't get the causality
right so you have a sense you don't know
you have well it's I mean this is one of
the things I wanted to get into but you
know there's no reason we need to go in
order so help me out understanding the
relationship between taste and smell
like when I was in grade school and I
learned about the five senses
I learned the taste and smell were
different things and then when I've
grown up people are increasingly telling
me that in fact taste depends on smell
is that is that completely accurate like
or is it just a slight exaggeration or
completely wrong and no actually this is
the the crucial bit will we often say
that taste depends on smell but I would
actually twist it around it'll even even
more so it tastes us really what you
perceive through your taste buds and if
you look at your tongue you've got salty
you've got pizza
you've got mommy sweet sour and
apparently not also fat actually so in a
couple of years ago the fat taste
receptors will discover it but all the
other things you actually perceive as
taste such as ascetic mean strawberry
licorice all these kind of things
there is no mint receptor on your tongue
so how can that be your perception of
the flavor and this is the the
phenomenon so flavor is what you
perceive through the nose and you might
wonder hey how about this how does that
work so what happens is when you chew
you've got the odor molecules released
from your food and they travel through
the back of your nose through the back
of your mouth you throw it to the open
space into your nose it's being pushed
up to the nose to the epithelium with
the air from your lungs so they hit yep
a theme and this is why when you have a
cold you don't smell anything and sadly
this phenomenon has become very very of
accurate and modern topic through curve
it's because one of the key symptoms is
that people suddenly stop smelling and
they're tracing yep precisely well okay
I think so this is an important moment
in my life because I think that actually
made perfect sense to me and I've never
understood it before so the taste buds
are sort of kind of a course thing that
that to give you senses of just a few
different textures in some sense
textures are not the right word but you
know salty and umami and sweet and so
forth whereas the details of the flavor
are coming through through smell is that
safe to say is that right absolutely
yeah and it's quite fascinating to think
how that all interacts because it shows
wonderfully how integrated the senses
interact because when we taste something
there's also texture and we are
influenced by the crunchiness also the
sound so to speak and there's been some
great studies looking at multi-sensory
cross sensory phenomena and of course
smell is one of the key aspects of that
issue okay okay this is great that's
very good so maybe this is the right
time to back up a little bit and talk
about the neuroscience of smell and
maybe it would be useful to contrast it
with the neuroscience of vision which
I'm sure many listeners are not
completely up on but I was always
surprised to learn I was surprised to
learn it the first time that we really
do have like a little part in the brain
in the visual cortex that basically maps
on to our visual field in a one-to-one
correspondence it really is like the the
detector of a video camera but nothing
like that is true for smell right I know
it's it's this is one of the things that
I find most fascinating so it's of
course a very simplified picture of
vision as well and I often get a bit of
pushback by visual researchers they were
it's a bit more complicated than that
I'm sure I I grow I grant you that but
the point is that smell is even more
complicated and that's the really cool
thing because it it prompts us to
rethink are these specific organizations
of the visual cortex we really you've
got certain activations in the retina
and you can trace where they project to
in the visual on the primary visual
cortex
there have been some really cool studies
on monkey brains to where they had a
monkey knee look at a certain kind of
stimulus and image and then later they
could actually through through some
metabolic traces they could dissect the
brain and show precisely that image as
the monkey saw it in the visual cortex
and it looked precisely like that so as
you say precisely assess a sudden you
find this map of the world in the visual
cortex and this is of course a very very
strong image it sounds fascinating gives
us this idea of that there is some
reality reflected in the brain and if we
just know how that image is there we we
have this objectivity we've got this
grounding in reality but smell doesn't
work like that it's this mosaic it just
hangs out it's beautiful but there is no
order and also it's different across
different individuals so you might
wonder how does the brain then know how
what it what a smell is what kind of
smell it is how similar it is to another
and that's the question that's been
engaging many researchers scientific or
factory scientists over the past couple
of decades and the short answer is we
still don't quite know but we're getting
there
longtime listeners know that I like to
talk about the great courses plus this
is a streaming service that gives you
access to a whole wide variety of
courses from the great courses that is
to say courses that are professionally
produced with some of the top lecturers
in the world talking about a wide
variety of topics from hoppy like things
you know from music and languages to
very highbrow academic things whether
it's science or philosophy history or
literature etc for example if you're
enjoying the podcast today about smell
and the philosophy thereof there's a
course at the great courses plus called
understanding the secrets of human
perception by peter vishton
which will tell you all about all of our
senses how they fit together and how
they help us conceive of the world in
different ways and the great courses
plus is extremely convenient there's an
app so you can view the courses on your
mobile devices as well as at home on
your TV with your family or whatever so
join me and see for yourself you can
sign up for the great courses plus today
and right now mindscape listeners get a
free trial of unlimited access to the
entire library so you can start your
free trial at the great courses plus.com
/ mind scape that's th e great courses
PLU s calm
/ mind scape I mean it kind of makes
sense to be coming as a as a physicist
as I usually do there's a kind of
linearity envisioned right there's the
location you're looking at the
brightness of what you're looking at and
the color and you can vary all of those
smoothly
whereas with smell it's really more of a
lock-and-key kind of thing you're you
have different compounds that interact
in complicated nonlinear ways with your
nose in your brain oh yeah absolutely
and what is I think this is what
fascinated me the most is because as you
say there seems to be this linear
trajectory in the visual system and of
course within that trajectory you can
always add more complexity but we smell
it already starts at the at the
molecular level so if you when you smell
you actually perceive airborne molecules
volatiles and what is really cool is
that even just a single molecule it's
not just simply one smell so if you
think of the comparison to vision where
you perceive electromagnetic wavelength
wavelength which is a Luo dimensional
stimulus so you really have the
receptors in your eyes chopping up the
spectrum into specific bits so you've
got the blue the green and the red
receptors and the further colors like
further colors come out of a combination
from these receptors
now we smell it's a bit more complicated
against one molecule doesn't just have
one smell so it's not just you see in
vision you only see the red you don't
see the blue at the same place where the
right is but someone who kills if you
smell them they have more than one
quality so there are some molecules if
you ever give your sis three hexanol
which is one of my favorite molecules it
smells of fresh-cut green grass but more
than fresh-cut green grass it also has a
leafy node and earthy nodes so there are
different kind of notes and qualities to
it and that's just a single molecule but
most of the things you smell are
mixtures hundreds of molecules Coffee
has about 800
so there is much more going on and it's
not that you have one receptor just
detecting one molecule but you've got a
community explosion so what I find
really cool is that you've got one
molecule can be detected by a variety of
different receptors and one receptor can
detect different parts of different
molecules so this is why we can smell so
many different things and furthermore we
can smell things that haven't existed in
nature before because we can synthesize
molecules that do not exist that do not
necessarily have a natural origin from a
plant or something and that might not
have any quality previously previously
known to mankind and still we will smell
it immediately we don't have to grow or
evolve new receptors otherwise perfume
perfumery would be pretty pretty in bad
shape let's put it that way yeah and if
you just do the non-linearity shows ups
in the sense that if you just change one
atom in a molecule it can smell
completely differently unlike if you
change the wavelength of a photon by a
little bit it looks almost exactly the
same yeah absolutely and really even
even not just even smell slightly
differently but being a complete
different quality so some molecule if
you if you change a small thing it goes
for instance from pair to banana so
completely different quality in
comparison it's it's quite striking and
some molecules also have directly two
qualities and there's one one example
which is one of my favorites is
enantiomers so these are molecules that
are identical in shape but they are
mirror imaged so you can't superimpose
them and there's one case some smell
alike in some dotes and there's one the
SA and the arc caverns and one is smell
smells of mint and the other of caraway
so completely different it's it's quite
striking when you say that something
smells of mint should I imagine that
that compound actually is appears in
mint or in the sentiment or is there
some family resemblance somehow oh
you're asking one of my favorite
questions because the answer is yes a
note so there are some molecules which
have its I know this is the
philosophical answer yes or no
but there are some molecules which are
very very
simulating structure and they have a
similar smell but you also have the
opposite that you've got molecules very
very similar in structure with
completely different smells and also
molecules that have completely unrelated
kinds of micro structures but very very
similar smells the same kind of category
my favorite example is musk so musk is a
it's an ingredient that's very popular
perfumery and you have some masks that
are for instance that have a signature
compound others have nitrogen in them so
there's they they had there's no
similarity between these molecules and
yet they're still part of the same
quality group right right so does that
mean that the wine people or the whiskey
people or the coffee people are not
crazy when they taste these you know
here's the scent of barnyard and
pomegranates and pencil shavings like
they're real there really is some
science that would back you lease up the
plausibility of actually detecting those
objectively absolutely so you mentioned
my favorite example namely wine tasters
the first time I I'll be honest with you
the first time I saw wine tasters I
thought they can't possibly smell that
you know they they smell the wine they
shake it a little bit they stir it a
little bit swirl it and then they go
with all these descriptors from or this
has kind of vanilla in it and oak and
well there is no oak tree in this wine
so how can you smell it and I just smell
you know red wine I mean its wine
I was very unsophisticated back then and
I thought I want to I want to know
what's going on here I want to learn
what these people can do and this is
where I realized oh hang on a second
this is incredibly cognitive process
this is highly analytic and really kind
of a Sherlock Holmes deductive way of
perceiving I mean wine tasters
especially experts on my years they do
this really not just for years for
decades to get to the point where they
can name a minute Lloyd what wine is
which vineyard which year and and all
these kind of things and it's not
wizardry and it's not some kind of con
artists tree they have a beautifully
cognitive way of doing that and there is
a is a movie for for the littles
actually want to google that
called some a couple of years ago it's
on Netflix and there so there's one
scene you can you can find directly by
so my guy called Ian Colville who in one
minute that uses the the kind of wine
and you think he talks faster than I do
even and I think like how can he how can
he come up with it and then you just
have to look at what he does because he
doesn't just smell and say okay this is
the Riesling from so-and-so he first
holds the glass at a 45 degree angle and
we wonder why is he doing that I mean it
looks very posh but that's not the
reason why they do that he looks at the
edges of the wine to see well how does
it actually reflect the light is there
any oil film on it that gives you
already kind of an idea of what kind of
wine it is based on the color based on
how how this caress it is and then you
see him swirling the glass and the
reason for that is that you basically
increase the surface of the wine and
you've got a broader bouquet coming out
of it especially more lighter notes and
more and in qualities and that's how you
start to develop some first hypothesis
and then he smells it again and they
just spout out these words which make no
sense quite often to anyone who's just
listening and in that scene he even goes
like well there's lime candy and lines
etc and he only mentions three actually
he doesn't give you that many different
descriptors he only gives you three
because there's also biological cap at
how many things we can instantaneous
instantaneously attacked or identified
in a mixture and then he breaks it down
even further because then he focuses in
his mind on specific qualities while his
idea in his mind it could be this wine
or it could be that wine I mean they
have a library of wines they learn to
recognize over years over decades and at
some point it starts a tasting to see
how much tannin like what's the acidity
so it's really just a step by step it's
not just sniffing and knowing what wine
it's really actually getting rid of all
potential things it is not and owning in
on what kind of wine it might be like go
through a mental library of potential
wines
popper would be very very happy at this
at this technique they falsified it
could be but I'll also mention mindscape
listeners know that we had an episode on
wine tasting with the local sommelier
matthew lutz ii and he talked about
exactly you know the process that you do
go through the first thing you ask is it
a thin-skinned grape or a thick-skinned
grape so it's not magic or BS there
really is some science there but you
make a good point which is that you
train yourself you can get better and
that extends beyond sommelier is right I
mean it's the sense of smell you make a
point in your book is one that we can
learn to be better at absolutely so
people often think that something is or
perfumers they must have these super
noses or some kind of freakish powers no
not at all they actually have normal
noses this is something everybody can
start to get better at and there have
been also some interesting studies
looking at people learning how to smell
doing smell training every day for 20
minutes and after six weeks which is
very very fast they could already record
changes in the thickness of the cortex
so it really changes your brain oh wow
okay so I thought you were to say that
they had really picked up some skills
but you could actually physiologically
measure how they've changed oh yeah they
also started to smell better I mean in
terms of detecting smells not just
smelling better themselves but yeah you
could actually really show that in the
brain um and that is what I found so
fascinating it's not just that it's it's
it's it's this integration of on the one
hand a cognitive skill and on the other
hand you can trace it in the brain this
is something that has a profound
physiological mechanism you can study
yeah I mean I want to get into a little
bit more the specific science of what
happens when someone smells something so
I mean it starts in tell me where it
starts in the nose or in the olfactory
bulb is that in the brain and there's
both the chemistry of how you your you
physiologically detect the chemical and
then there's the neuroscience of how you
interpret it precisely so the olfactory
pathway is beautiful because it looks
pretty straightforward however it turns
out a bit more
complicated than that but it's three
steps basically the first step is that
you've got the molecules interacting
with the epithelium in your nose where
the receptors are situated in the
sensory neurons where they interact in
this combinatorial fashion and that
signal is then sent further to the
olfactory bulb which is at the frontal
lobe like right at the front of your
brain and it's really really it's just
one synapse into it and what is really
cool is that you must imagine that
you've got millions of cells in your
epithelium detecting all these smells in
a combinatorial fashion so you've got
one molecule hitting a couple of let's
say 10 20 different receptors activating
them now imagine you've got 800 in
coffee imagine what kind of mosaic
explosion on your on your epithelial
must happen so how does the how does how
does the brain then know where is coming
what and what's what's the drama etc the
real cool thing is that the second step
there's a beautiful engineering trick of
the olfactory brain namely you've got
every sensor in urine expresses only one
receptor so there is already kind of
some order and then the next thing is
like all these sensory neurons with her
which have one specific kind of receptor
humans have about 400 different types
these neurons with one receptor converge
in one particular place called
glomerulus which is a spherical neural
structure in the olfactory bulb and so
what the consequence out of that is that
you actually have a spatial pattern in
the bulb so you've got like an
individual fingerprint for each molecule
that's the second step the third step
this is where it gets messy in is that
they both then further projects its
signal so it sends its signal to the
primary olfactory cortex which has the
beautiful name period for cortex because
it's shaped like a pear form and this is
where the big difference between the V
between olfaction and the visual system
emerges because if the olfactory system
was like vision you would have this kind
of map also in the V in the olfactory
cortex you would have it maintained but
it's not actually it dispersed that it
goes all kind of directions it's a
mosaic it's mayhem it's
chaos so these three steps is facing
what olfaction is about and you would
think actually hang on a second if it's
so simple what's the difficulty and this
was one of the things by Monique aha
already noted a beginning of the 20th
century saying what a faction might be
the best model of the brain you can have
because it only has two synapses
straight into the cortex from the ear to
the brain the most direct pathway for
sensory perception so if we can crack
that we might understand how we perceive
how we think and well just for
comparison to synapses don't even get
you out of the retina in vision so this
is why people this is simple we can do
this we march through the system and we
know how it works and then a couple of
decades later well maybe it's not that
simple there's lots of stuff going on
here we we haven't figured out so but in
some sense can I analogize it to like a
big data problem
there's an enormous amount of
information coming into the nose and
somehow I don't know the brain does a
principal component analysis and says oh
yes that smells like pencil shavings or
something like that yes I know I like
the comparison on the one in you're
absolutely right there is a big data
problem because you're hit with so many
signals but there's something more
towards just figuring out what the
signal means it's also that the signal
itself is ambiguous because what people
often forget is that molecules don't
just have different qualities to them
but they also appear in different
contexts and with these contexts come
different behavioral meanings so my
favorite example is is a is the next
it's an experiment that was done in 2001
by Rachel Hertz actually where she gave
people two vials and they looked almost
identical and how'd it break I come to
in a moment how that links to our
conversation but she gave these people
two vials and one was called parmesan
and the other was conformant and people
were ruling us yeah yeah I mean people
were adamant these are different smells
and they had a preference of course for
parmesan and I mean
I'm pretty sure there was always one
person went like oh no I actually like
vomit but people are adamant and she did
there was different kind of pairs now
the interesting thing is it was the same
mixture it was a mixture of Patera
Cassatt and people added they didn't
realize that it was the same mixture and
it's often kind of used as Allah see
this is why smell is so unreliable and
it's just illusionary illusionary no not
at all because both parmesan and vomit
do you contain butyric acid you have
certain molecules in different context
giving you completely different meanings
in this case food and contaminants so
you must imagine that you have a
promiscuous stimulus that just means
different things in different parts so
different qualities are more prominent
so the sensory system of olfaction needs
to figure out what is the context in
which this signal means that or it means
that
or it means that you have much more
information than the brain is basically
processing and bring it bring it into
conscious awareness and then I found
super interest because it goes a little
bit against the idea of a map when it
comes not just the brain mapping reality
but also the mind
picturing on mirroring reality in a more
philosophical sense but it's much more
about ok we like our brain measures
basically what is there and in what kind
of Grady in what kind of concentration
and what kind of context is it more is
it less and the mind is much more in
terms of ok you you basically have a
contextual affiliation you've got a
behavioral measure that is tailored to
your body that is tailored to the
environmental context you've got a
statistical evaluation of where you are
and what you need so to speak and that's
a pretty cool thing to to have as a
sense and this is why smell is much more
accurate actually than people think I
mean there was a little bit worried that
you'd bring up this example of Parmesan
cheese and vomit because it's it's an
incredibly good example I mean it's
obviously the right one to use but on
the other hand I worry that you have
ruined Parmesan cheese for me forever
I'm not I'm not sure how I'm gonna deal
with this going forward in my life yeah
I'm sorry I ruined pasta and the thing
is nobody has vomit ruined for them
ironically but this is something I find
super festive nobody went like oh yeah
vomit smell sure
like parmesan no I can taste it yes but
should I think of this I mean I guess
this is where we begin to get
philosophical so the it's the power of
suggestion in some very hand wavy sense
but it's also the power of context as
you said we have a brain that perceives
a certain chemical reaction but then the
words that we attach to it absolutely
depend on what else we're thinking about
and so forth and is the idea that maybe
vision is the same way and it's just as
bad we just don't notice is it or is it
just use it there a lesson to be drawn
about how we construct models of the
world based on our sensory inputs these
are two good questions the first it's
not with it with the one in terms of
well is its vision just like that
perhaps yes and no on the one hand I
think we can learn about vision from
that example because we do have vision
is not just simply from input to to the
perception there's a lot of stuff going
on which we often call illusions where
context matters also how we interpret
images and then some visual images that
actually are not well understood because
it is very contextual such as faces for
instance and I think there's a good
analogy between faces and smells often
because they're very individualized we
do have to learn how to discriminate
them think of for instance twins well
after a while we actually figure out how
they're different but there is something
may is something different as well there
are some similarities when it comes to
context and in certain visual effects
for instance it's much less
straightforward then we often like to
think but there is something different
about smell when it comes to precisely a
certain form of context reality and also
the fact that it's not just one physical
thing in the world having one kind of
meaning and it's being constructed by
the brain inserts and kind of
perspective and variant ways so objects
are perspective invariants in envision
if I turn around my table here will
still look like a table but if i spritz
an odor in different context to you you
will think it's a different quality a
different mental object and it's not in
terms of all because smells are so
ephemeral and unreliable but it just
means in a different context you your
brain is focusing on different facets on
different nodes of the odor and it
elicits a different mental image it's
just it's doing something different and
that is philosophically interesting I
mean maybe the senses do have different
functions they have integrated they do
work in tandem with each other but we
shouldn't just model all these things is
based on one sense which has been vision
mainly I mean there's a famous
philosophical question which I've always
thought it was a little bit misguided is
the read that you are experiencing the
same as the read that I'm experiencing
is thinking about smells instead shed
any light on this oh yes so I I have to
be honest I hate I hate the whole qualia
debate so much I possibly shouldn't say
this too loud but then again I'm not
anymore but I always found this is one
of the most ridiculous philosophical
debates you can imagine and the reason
why smell is actually a good case to
show we're kind of missing the point of
understanding how the senses work is
through smell because quite often people
say see you smell is so subjective and
varying between individuals even within
the same individual so can't really know
what you're smelling or I'm smelling but
it's actually traceable through
fundamental physiological and genetic
processes to explain why we have the
variation so there's a difference
between variation and subjectivity
subjectivity means just like it's in
your head there's no relation no
grounding and objective reality but
variation just means well there's a
difference in perception but we can
bring that variation we can link that
variation to certain causal principles
and these can be studied objectively so
they're really really recently it was a
series of studies showing that a lot of
the perceptual variation in smell links
to the high like the super EXTREME
genetic diversity between humans with a
sense of smells so your factory system
is one of the genetically most diverse
systems and there's a good example
do you like cilantro I like cilantro yes
I know you're talking about good but
many people were not
so I I often ask my students for instant
class who of you doesn't like cilantro
because there are some people who don't
perceive it as fresh but it's kind of
pungent or soapy it just doesn't taste
nice
these are mutants in the sense like in a
kind of x-men mutants they have a
genetic mutation near one of the
olfactory receptor genes so you can
actually link certain differences
towards material causes so it's not
subjective and it shows a bit that the
quest of is my blue the same as your
blue that's asking the wrong question
that's just a pseudo problem of
separating the mental image from the
cause of processes that actually create
that image and this is what we need to
study in order to understand how it is
that we perceive the world and how we
also can perceive the same thing
differently or sometimes perceive it the
same yeah raw tomatoes actually I happen
to know because my wife Jennifer cannot
stand the taste of raw tomatoes and it
turns out that there's a mutation that
there's a surprisingly large number of
people who just can't stand it and they
get it's interesting because it also
goes into like social norms like if you
don't like raw tomatoes unlike cilantro
which people can take or leave but if
you don't like the taste of raw tomatoes
people judge you oh you're just not a
good taste or a good human being or
something like that it's weird how we we
go from this manifestly personal thing
to moral judgments very very quickly
yeah absolutely right I I hadn't thought
of that for a long time but you're right
we often speak of taste of tastelessness
I'm surprised a that people would judge
you because look you don't like tomatoes
wow that's harsh well their vegetables
they're supposed to be healthy for you
right like yeah it's a you know society
society doesn't like people who deviate
from the norms in many ways I just did a
podcast a short while ago with Olga
Kazan who same thing like she did the
whole thing about being weird and how
society judges you very quickly so the
fact that people have different sense
responses to the world is something that
gets and becomes normative very very
quickly which is a shame actually
because I think this is where we're
smell is such a fascinating topic
because you can extend your perception
and your perspective on how others
perceive it and you can connect it much
more by understanding where that
variation comes from well it's just it's
it's it's not just simply some whim but
you can explain it causally and you can
also extend your perception - sometimes
perceive what the other person is
perceiving so if you can learn for
instance to detect certain notes if you
have the wine taster tells you oh yeah
this Riesling wine has some petrol in it
or there's this one which has cat pee in
it I kid you not these are real
descriptors you think these people are
weird like how can you smell cat pee in
wine well and if you if you train if you
if you for instance what what wine
tasters do is they have benchmark
reference odorants they may smell and
they then identify in Dec mixture so at
some point you will smell the pee in the
wine you will smell the petrol in the
wine it's a it's a distinctive smell and
you can extend your own perception you
can reach out also to how others
perceive the world and this is why I
actually like what you get like what you
see is not what you get in a certain way
to turn it around it's like well what
you smell can be many different things
and you have to actually cognitively
evaluate and train to figure out what
different things you can perceive you
can augment your consciousness you can
augment your access to conscious
perception it's a beautiful sense yeah
and the origin of these I guess I keep
trying one of calling them
subjectivities but individuality Zin how
we perceive senses are very interesting
you make the point in the book that the
olfactory bulb is sort of I guess have
just put it the structure of your
olfactory bulb which is this
intermediate step between your nose in
your brain is not purely determined by
the genes that code for it there's a
developmental aspect as well oh yeah and
that's one of the most fascinating
things and I noticed it's it's something
where people like it what what does it
matter whether it's developmentally
induced kind of a spatial structure
develop
reduced or genetically predetermined
there is a huge difference so you must
imagine that when you have the bulb
you've got a spatial pattern that
represents the chemical input however
it's different in genetically diverse
organisms so you actually have a
different neural representation of a
stimulus in different individuals
because it's not there to give you a map
or some kind of chemical classification
of the stimulus it's not in your brain
that like in the bulb that you would
have the aldehydes next to the ketones
or you would have some other qualities
next like rows next to lavender but
further away from mint that's not what's
happening
you've got similar ordering sometimes in
different areas and different odors
sometimes in more closely related areas
what's happening here is was something
much more I find subtle and cool Namie
you've got a measure of what's actually
in your environment is kind of chemical
features how often do they occur it's a
measure of contrast like what's more
what's less and you might wonder okay
why well one of the reasons is that our
chemica environment is so diverse
there's this you're constantly
surrounded by hundreds of molecules and
humans change habitats so we often move
a lot we move a lot not just in terms of
our daily for earth circles and and
habits but even just moving around
I mean I'm originally from Germany I
moved to England I moved to Australia to
New York and then to Bloomington other
people might move for instance to
Singapore or to South Africa etc so
there are so many different chemical
environments and the real cool thing is
that after a while your nose actually
changes the expression of receptor
patterns to adapt to to actually
accommodate these different chemical
environments so you need a much more
flexible system to be able to respond to
something in an accurate and in a
behavioral relevant manner so in some
sense the sense of smell is more we said
it's sort of context dependent but it's
also more context adaptive than the
sense of sight like you know our vision
is more or less the same no matter where
we go but the sensory input the weak
from smell does depend on the
environment we're in absolutely spot-on
man and this is this is where I thought
this is cool because this gives us a
beautiful way to think about how we
should how we should model the mind as
in interaction with our environment it's
not just a mirror of things it's really
actually how the organism is always in
an interaction with the environment and
it shapes how we perceive and it shapes
also the physiological basis that allow
us to perceive these things it's it's
quite cool yeah and so good so this gets
into the the philosophical weeds a
little bit because I abstract it that
part of what you're saying is a response
against or pushback against the idea
that the job of our senses is to make a
map of the world right I mean we have
this metaphor that we are little video
cameras or something like that and
there's a three-dimensional space that
we're in and we map it out and we call
that reality and you're saying that if
we were more olfactory centric we would
have a very different set of metaphors I
think so I think so I did we would we
would stop thinking about mirrors for
instance and we would also it wouldn't
be about that what is objective on what
is real is measured by we all perceive
the same thing we all have the same kind
of image but it's much more about
perception is not a mirror it's not a
representation of something but it's an
acquisition it's an it's an augmentation
of consciousness and it's a constant
evaluation so it's not that what gets
into the brain and gets mirrored but
more what's the brain for how do we
respond to our environment and also how
can we learn quite a lot of perception
and this is also the link to cognition
is we don't just have things somehow
being projected to into our mind and
suddenly there's the image we have to
learn how to see things as well we just
forget that we have to do it because we
were we were kids at some point and a
lot of things where we're kind of under
like not not conscious anymore we don't
have it in our memory but we smell we
constantly have to learn it and this is
the big difference why I think it's it's
important to go beyond vision is
and the kind of image metaphors with
vision everything is in your
consciousness right away and we track
things because we can just see things
moving with smell they pop in and out of
consciousness
and we have to we have difficulties of
finding out what the same thing is over
different instances so it tells us
something about to what extent we have
to learn to recognize things we have to
learn to even just to know what certain
things are and what context they are and
I think it gives us a better
understanding of to what extent what we
think of our world is actually it's not
it's not relative in the sense that
whatever like anything goes but it is
learn it is a quiet to a certain extent
and you make the point that there's a
sense in which the amount of sensory
input we get from smell is enormous ly
larger than what we're consciously aware
of right we we filter out all the
background very effectively and that
made me think of an interview I did
recently with Robin Carhartt Harris
about the use of psychedelics in to
treat patients and and just for
therapeutic reasons because apparently
like if you take LSD or something like
that a you know psychedelic that that
makes you see visions and so forth the
argument is that those visions are
always there but we our brain filters
them out I mean these are what we're
doing is just sort of lowering the
barriers to the ongoing noise that is in
our brain in some sense and I wonder if
if there is if anyone has looked at you
know psychedelics and smell you do we
smell more of the world or do we re
aware more of what we're smelling all
the time if we lower our barriers or our
filters in that way absolutely so there
this is one of the things that quite
often you don't think smell is that
important because you don't pay
attention to it but as soon as you do so
as soon as you start focusing on smells
and how your environment smells and you
train your nose for instance to
recognize certain wines or you go
outside you actually it's its first
looks at oh yeah because I told you that
but people might say yeah maybe but
actually it doesn't lower the threshold
of detection so
smells you're familiar with and you
train yourself to recognize you have a
lower threshold just physiologically to
detect them so you literally learn how
to perceive more of the world how to
detect more of the world and then
cognitively to get a much more subtle
picture and it's actually not that far
removed from vision so if you if you for
instance think of how many things we we
see just not consciously change
blindness these kind of things it's kind
of similar we smell as soon as you train
yourself to know what to pay attention
to you start to perceive more qualities
more things and at least with smell the
nice thing is you also lower your
threshold for what you can detect so
molecules and lower concentrations yeah
it does remind me of the whole set of
ideas concerning embodied cognition and
the idea that it's a mistake to think of
the brain as this sort of isolated
reasoning computer really our brains our
minds are in our bodies and that really
matters and I mean maybe the fact that
we're constantly smelling and for that
matter probably tasting hearing touching
things in the world is an important part
of this permeable membrane that connects
us to the outside reality so I'm one of
those people who's on the one hand fond
of embodied cognition and on the other
hand very critical of it which might
sound strange given given what I said
about this interaction with the
environment but in in a certain way I am
actually quite near eccentric my issue
with embodiment ideas is that they kind
of take this brain almost also separate
from the body like well you perceive
outside your brain in the body it's like
well your brain is part of the body of
course how your body interacts is going
to have certain changes in effects in
the brain and in order to understand the
brain you of course have to understand
the body but I don't think that means
something in the sense of oh well we
perceive outside the brain in terms of
the best any any any form of causal
primacy of the process there's some
philosophers such as Arbor knowing Wood
who wrote this book out of our mind or
out of our heads where he kind of makes
the claim that it's we were perceived
outside the brain which sends ultimate
of the brain
I don't know about that so much because
I read too much Oliver Sacks and I saw
what can go wrong so I I just think
there are too many cases showing just
because there is a very very big
importance to be placed on the body it
doesn't mean that the brain is not the
central organ I'm much more along the
lines of Patricia Churchland yeah who's
also on the one hand very Eurocentric
and on the other hand also takes into
account evolutionary processes and
embodied parts but actually to
understand the brain as the central
processing organ okay
neuro centric I like that that's a
perfectly a good thing to be I mean
there's an ongoing I'm sure that this is
one of those questions where everyone is
a little bit right you know and we're
trying to figure out what the balance is
obviously the body matters obviously the
senses in the external world matter
obviously the neurons matter as well so
that's a good thing to keep to keep in
mind but does this have does it can we
bring this back to questions I know you
you gave your opinion on qualia very
good the other thing the other thing
that people are going to want to know
about is free will you know if we think
that we are our brains our physical
systems obeying laws of nature there you
know determined and so forth is our
sense of smell affecting how we reason
and how we make choices like how much
should our sense of smell and and how we
perceive the environment around us
through olfaction changing decisions
that we make I see you're coming with a
kind of easy questions
look we're highly paid academics your
biggest questions come on that is a
great question so let's put it that way
there is a lot of things when it comes
to our decisions that these decisions
are definitely influenced by smell and
quite often in a way that we might not
consciously process my favorite example
is actually partner choice so we would
we often like to think especially when
we're listening to two songs and reading
poetry that you know we're looking for
our soul mate and there's some romantic
connection about
you know I like that person because she
or he is funny and etc etc etc actually
it's much more physical and smell is a
good part of that and it's just is
necessarily consciously so there was a
really cool study showing that women
prefer men they did they did a body odor
test so they gave women some t-shirts to
smell which men had worn and they
preferred the smell of men with it who
had a complementary immune system so
there was a slide genetic difference and
now comes now comes their about the real
shocker because women who were on the
pill who had a hormonal change change
their preferences they had a preference
for men or the body odor of men with a
more similar immune system to themselves
and I thought this might explain some
divorce rates because when do people get
the worst well shortly after marriage
when they get rid of contraceptive
routines like oh wow so the love of your
life might really lose some sex appeal
after after marriage if you change your
contraceptive routine like ouch
this is people don't like to hear that
because we would like to think of humans
as as these kind of rational agents and
it's not that we're irrational but we
are physical creatures and smell is an
important part because it tells us a lot
of things it tells us about whether
somebody is sick for instance it tells
us also about the dietary habits of some
somebody because the meta metabolic
changes and the emanation from your skin
they tell you something about the be
healthy the the chemical immolations of
another person and that also has some
great medical applications so a
colleague who are interviewed for
instance for the book and res Mershon he
got interested in looking at can we
detect cancer through changes in body
odor so can we divide develop little
electronic noses that record the body
odor and if there's a certain change for
instance it would alert you to check
with your dermatologist to go to your
doctor and oh no yeah well I know this
is actually very susceptible to that
because you might know like well hang on
a second we can't possibly perceive that
we can it's just often unconscious and
some people
there are few people who actually gain
some you could say attention also in
popular science there's the case of the
British nurse joy moon who became famous
for sniffing out Parkinson's so she
sniffs their t-shirts of patients and
says this guy is Parkinson this woman is
Parkinson and she's right and so the
implication of this is that when we say
oh I broke up with this person because
they were financially irresponsible it
might just be because we didn't like how
they smelled or our brains our
subconscious didn't like how they smell
it could be it so you know when you meet
somebody new and let's put it that way
that person can be the funniest most
attractive wittiest smartest person if
this smell is off if it's often caught
you can't it's something that just
closes the deal in terms of no it just
breaks video it's just something we we
cannot get simply over we might get we
might adapt to somebody's bad humor but
not to somebody's bad smell so that
would you know go along in the direction
of saying that we're a little bit less
perfectly rational reasonable creatures
and we'd like to think we are we we
justify our choices ex post facto but
probably a large amount of our
decision-making is just these these
factors we don't even know about we're
not even aware of I think that's a good
point because it is not necessarily less
rational it's just that they are factors
we're not necessarily consciously aware
of and I think it's a there is a form of
biological rationality and rationality
in scare quotes to to actually follow
your nose in in that sense because it
does tell you about the hidden things
the things that are not visible so a lot
of things they might look nice but they
might be rotten to the core
I mean you smell you smell your milk you
don't look at it if you take it out of
the fridge so there is a it's not
irrational to actually follow your nose
we just have a very very kind of
abstract view of decision-making when it
comes to why we decide for certain
things and this is where is actually
interested to look at what
are the factors that a make it into
conscious decisions and be really
influenced our our choices yeah okay I
think that's right that's a better way
of putting it it's just the point being
that it's less our cognitive rational
part of our mind that is doing the
decision-making then we like to give it
credit for but it still might be our
sensible irrational you know uh
[Music]
maximizing some kind of utility kind of
decision absolutely and to bring this
back to the big question of free will it
does tell us something about how we make
choices also in different contexts and
how these choices have a biological
basis and how there's always like
different levels to what we mean by
choice what we mean by will certain
choices might have been willed and some
choices we think will for different
reasons then potentially that
potentially actually informed the
decision I mean I think it just shows
how how we shouldn't frame any notion of
freewill based on what I think was the
reason for my decision and should work
and should just expand the different
levels of what informs our choices here
okay let me switch gears a little bit
because I can't let you go without
digging into this question of science
and philosophy right I mean who better
that I could talk to I know plenty of
people who got PhDs in science and then
moved into philosophy I don't know that
many who started out as philosophers and
then started a lab I mean maybe there
are others I don't know maybe you can
mention some of the big names in the
field but how do you conceptualize both
what the relationship of science and
philosophy should be and also how it is
in the real world of academia big
question I I love that you're asking
vets
because the you know how we often like
to say interdisciplinarity we all want
to be interdisciplinary and I kind of I
gotta be honest I let's be really honest
it's very very hard for the reasons that
you really have to learn an entire new
field and you often hear people talking
about putting their different hats on
like oh if I talked to a neuroscientist
like with my neuroscience hat on if I
talk to philosophers I talked
put my philosophy hat on I don't think
this is the kind of interdisciplinarity
that we really should aim for especially
when we think of something of the
integration of science and philosophy
but it's much more to develop a
integrated expertise that goes beyond
just having two different hats and more
in terms of what kind of what kind of
future questions can we derive through
the integration my favorite example for
this actually Duke Jansky who wrote
genetics in the original species at the
beginning of the 20th century in the
first half and if you look at the book
yeah there are new no new data there's
actually nothing new in that book but
the book became foundational for the for
the new synthesis for the integration of
evolutionary theory to have it was you
know a United field and to integrate
genetics and Natural History really
hated each other back then and he did
that by an integration that prompted new
questions a new perspective on how to
look at the data and this is the the
role of philosophy anse and science in
integration I actually also would like
to see a little bit more in in current
developments as you say correctly there
are more scientists who at some point
develop an interest in the history and
philosophy of science and actually the
scientists I spend most of my time with
in the in the lab of Sethos Stein he was
the kind of person so he he is the kind
of person so he does a lot of science
but he became more and more interest in
the history philosophy of science and
that's how we ended up being together in
a lab and ironically while he's writing
more and more philosophy oriented books
I'm starting a lot because at some point
I thought you know I wanted more we like
to say that philosophy can inform
science by providing rationalization of
an analysis of models and conceptual
foundations and clarification I thought
well that's all very nice but I wanted
something more productive because there
is a way in which philosophy used to be
natural philosophy there used to be a
way of asking questions through the
experimental investigation through the
material basis that
deeply philosophical in nature so to
bring natural philosophy back into the
21st century and have a much more
integrated role or philosophy not just
as a as an analysis and observer but
really actually as a producer of good
questions and that's why I'm so much of
a fan of parchment because many people
reduce her work of neuro philosophy to
oh there's this idea but the the mind is
the brain and we have to explain mental
concepts through the brain she did
something much more radical something I
absolutely started to to understand only
when I was in the lab I mean her big
idea was really that the signs
neuroscience has advanced so vastly so
many new things came into our into into
our general knowledge that like you
could say that challenged traditional
philosophical notions of what the mind
is what certain mental concepts such as
memory are so maybe we should ask new
philosophical questions that are rising
out of the contemporary developments of
science and that's what I saw these kind
of opportunity was smell so there are
lots of questions coming out of that
that are deeply philosophical the the
current questions and all factory signs
are philosophical questions starting
with a seemingly simple question what
are artists what what what do they we
present what kind of information is
actually processed in the brain these
are deeply philosophical I did I had Pat
Churchland as a guest on mindscape and
it was interesting to me that if I'm
remembering correctly she said that her
approach to neuro philosophy got much
more positive feedback from scientists
than from philosophers in general I was
surprised by that oh I I'm not actually
I very much agree with her on that
because I had the same experience the
philosophers didn't really think that
Patterson was doing proper philosophy
whatever that means and there was a lot
of you could say discipline or
disciplinary gatekeeping and it's still
happening
I had unfortunately even even now I mean
I'm much later than than Patricia
Churchland
started this idea of your philosophy but
I still had the same challenges and
problems I heard so often I heard is
that still philosophy or why's that
photography or how is the philosophy and
I thought well it is it is a way of
philosophy that it used to be I mean
there's a very limited view of what
philosophy can do and should do and it
was accepted much more positively by the
scientists when I when I talked to the
variety of scientists for the book me
then they actually were incredibly
welcoming they liked this idea and they
really said well actually you know we
like these ideas have you thought of
going experimental there was a
conversation I had with Gordon Shepard
who's one of those prominent
neuroscientists but especially also a
factor in neuroscience and he set me
down for breakfast and I thought oh I'm
interviewing him for my book wonderful
like I had an interview with him already
but there was some follow-up questions
Gordon had a bit of different ideas
because he saw a talk I gave him he's
like okay have you thought of going
experimental because these are
philosophical ideas sure but they're
also applicable in an experimental
setting have you tried it have you
thought of trying that and his
confidence in in the possibility of
doing that and that I could do that was
for me the kind of last push to say okay
I want to learn an experimental
technique I this is this is how the
whole shenanigans started so to speak
yes and I mean do you think this might
be too bold but do you think that there
is intrinsically any barrier at all
between science and philosophy or do you
think it's just a continuum and the
structure of academia into departments
and faculties is what breaks it up like
that
hmm I don't think that's an intrinsic
barrier when it comes to philosophy as a
practice and science as a practice there
are difference in the way we we we we
conceive of them but I think it should
be more integrated and so I would go
with with your second part and say it's
quite often the way we institutionalize
these different the these different
disciplines and put them not just in
different places for different
departments and also how these different
areas cultivated their own their own
language their discos are
really started to delineating what it is
that is philosophy or what it is there
is a certain science and this is where I
quite like cognitive science because
it's such a smorgasbord of different
approaches you have computer simulations
wet lab research at philosophers who do
some form of cognitive science this is
much more where I would like to see also
philosophers and neuroscientists
interact a bit more I'm afraid there is
a lot of disciplinary gatekeeping and
yeah I think it's mainly the way we we
organize academia we organize
publications it's very hard to get
anything that is truly interdisciplinary
funded and published not it's it's a
buzzword but it's hardly really
implemented ya know I mean it was a
leading question I'm completely on your
side here and it's been very frustrating
for me that like I the work that I do
the research that I do has become more
along the lines of things that are
sympathetic to philosophers of physics
and you know people say are you moving
into philosophy and I'm and my attitude
is I'm not doing anything different in
the world like I don't care what you
want to call it but then when in the
real world do you have to apply for
grants you know you apply for jobs you
go to conferences and whether it's
physics or philosophy or whatever
matters a lot suddenly because we have a
structure that cares deeply about this I
totally agree yes and I agree with you
to say I don't care with its philosophy
or whether it's signs I'm interested in
question I'm interested in a problem and
you just in the world yes so I would I
would very very much agree with you and
this is I noticed there are a number of
people who are sharing their
frustrations so it's actually it's
actually many more people than then I
thought there would be and what is
really cool to see is that this a new
generation especially in philosophy of
science many PhD students many postdocs
who are really trying to go out there
they're talking to scientists there
they're also doing interviews there
they're trying to do observations of
laboratories some are also starting to
fine experimental approaches that gives
me hope that gives me a lot of her I
just feel bad because there at some
point we'll be on the job market it is a
worry but the kids are alright don't
figure some things out that us old
fogies it's too late for us but I do
have to ask you know I mean it's easy
for me to write a paper that appears in
a philosophy journal cuz I'm a
theoretical physicist and you know the
actual action that I'm doing sitting at
my desk scribbling equations doesn't
change at all but you had to set up a
lab which must be a bit of culture shock
like what was the biggest thing that you
learned or was surprising in the process
of setting up a lab which I personally
would have no idea how to even begin
doing uh welcome yes welcome to what
went on in my mind I have no idea
yes so I had to actually acknowledge the
fact of how little I really know in a
positive sense I think I actually had
one advantage over the scientists doing
that which is I know how little I
actually know I know my limits I might
not always know what I don't know so to
speak but I do know that this Shipton's
official metric [ __ ] tons of things I
really still have to learn that also
means I just asked people so the last
years I've been I've been talking to so
many different scientists I feel
comfortable saying sorry I don't know
what that means or what do I do here and
I realized one wonderful thing I mean
this is where I got more and more in
honored with the way the scientific
community works it's much more lot much
less isolated than philosophy that
people were happy to help you so I drew
in a way happy that I thought wow they
really went out of their way to tell me
okay you should really think about this
this is a bit more ambiguous depends on
what you want to do and they make you
think and one of my friends and
colleagues he he actually went like when
I told him like listen I actually must
must be honest I'm I'm a little bit you
know insecure here and he's like
listening he's like he's approaching the
80s now and he's like well you know
when I started my lab or was 28 and the
machine I wanted to use was just
invented so I asked them every kind of
question I'm pretty sure I had no idea
what I was talking about and welcome to
the club kiddo
so we all have to we have to all go
through that kind of fire and I learned
a lot and I learned that the only way to
approach science it's not that there's
some kind of hidden barrier some kind of
secret Club it's really just actually
acknowledging that you might not know
everything and actually you will not
know everything but you will learn how
to make better decisions based on asking
better questions and you acquire new
skills and with these new skills you
will realize more and more of what you
don't know and this is where
philosophical training is actually off
advantage and I think this is why
philosophy of science should be integral
to scientific education because you
learn how to ask the questions in a in a
way that I think the scientists would
value and if it also suit value I hope
at some point a bit more also to get an
idea of how these fellows of your
questions matter very thin conceptual
analysis of science but also actually
setting up a lot lab what are the things
I don't know what issues might actually
play into a certain measurement that I
haven't even thought about so yeah and I
should say I also had the advantage that
I'm literally coming from the laboratory
that brought your ignorance and failure
so I came from stewards lab and he
talked a lot he's not your
garden-variety scientist I mean he wrote
a book on ignorance he wrote a book on
failure
provocative titles but really to say
science is not the accumulation of facts
but the way to ask better questions and
the way we do that is really
accumulating more and more knowledge but
with that knowledge it's more like a
sphere you've got the circumference of
ignorance your knowledge grows your
ignorance grows you just ask more and
more sophisticated questions about the
things you don't know yeah no I think
that you know it's it's it was a sad day
when not only did Natural Philosophy
split off from science but they went
into completely different schools in the
university right I think it's not just a
different department but one is
humanities and one of Sciences that
makes it very difficult to to cross over
sometimes but okay one last question
when are we gonna get smell-o-vision we
are no sounds engine over our TV sets
but when are we gonna get the smells so
let's put it that way it depends on what
you want so you can have you know you've
got sometimes these kind of cinematic
experiences where they spritz a couple
of odors air into the room while you
watch a movie I gotta be honest I find
that's super distracting
it's just perhaps because I am so
sensitive to what smell it's just like I
can't concentrate on too many things and
it just brings me out of that immersive
state yeah
I recently actually saw on Twitter I was
in a debate where the question was well
can I record a smell and and send it
digitally to somebody else and it's a
nice idea but it's not going to work and
why it's actually that well you would
have to have you would have to record
let's say just this coffee with 800
molecules every coffee brand is
different you would have to release
exactly the same molecules in that
composition on the other hand now
imagine how many molecules are around
you would have to have a an indefinite
library of different odorants on the
other hand and on the other side being
released so it's it's it's impractical
it's impossible and the only thing you
can have is that you might have some
kind of device next to your computer
with some cartilage of predefined sense
like a limited number that just when you
push a button releases a certain scent
but that's yeah that's kind of mmm not
really interesting if I made might be
like actually yeah sorry that that makes
perfect sense wouldn't you we go back to
your point that it's difficult to have
olfactory illusions right in some sense
TV and movies are visual illusions they
make us think that we're seeing this
thing which we're really not but doing
that percent is much harder it is it
actually is because if you think of me
I'm sorry to bring it up again but the
parmesan vomits the thing it's on it's
it's it's not an illusion because both
is correct it is both parmesan and
vomits
you can't really trick your nurse it's
it's not that you're fooling your nose
they're just putting the emphasis on a
different part of the image so yeah I'm
innocent I would be hotter yep okay I
will not buy stock in any smellivision
companies that's good financial advice
but I will but I will be continually
amazed at the wonderful things that we
can do at the inter disciplinary
boundaries between philosophy and
science oh and Sophie bar [ __ ] thanks
so much for appearing on the mindscape
podcast well thank you so so much for
having me this was a lot of fun yeah I
think so
all right thanks very much and everyone
should buy the book please do
[Music]
you
[Music]